in this session we will look at all the
six functions in trigonometry using a
right triangle
let this be angle theta this will be the
site adjacent to theta this will be the
side opposite to theta and this is the
hypotenuse we learned the formula of the
sine cosine and tangent functions using
this right triangle the code we used to
remember the formula is sohcahtoa
so tells us that sine theta equals
opposite by hypotenuse da tells us that
cos theta equals adjacent by hypotenuse
and tor tells us that tan theta equals
opposite by adjacent apart from these
three functions there are three more
functions we need to understand let me
warn you beforehand the names sound
scary very scary but if you know the
formulae of these three functions they
would be really simple the name of the
forth function is cosecant the fifth
function is secant and the sixth one is
cotangent there you go
the funniest part about these names is
that none of them gives us a slightest
hint of what they mean take cosecant for
example we know that a secant is a line
that intersects the circle at two points
but varies the circle where is the line
and where are the two points anyway the
cosecant of theta is written as cosec
theta sometimes it's also written as CSC
theta but we will be using cosec in our
videos the formula is simple it's the
reciprocal of sine theta sine theta is
opposite by hypotenuse cosec theta is
hypotenuse by opposite the secant
function is written as sec theta and
guess what that's the reciprocal of cos
theta reciprocal of cos theta is
hypotenuse by adjacent the cotangent
function is written as cot theta and
the cotangent function is also the
reciprocal of the tangent function so it
equals the reciprocal of opposite by
adjacent which is adjacent by opposite a
layman looking at a board would be so
confused a right triangle some angle six
weird names a random code yes it's true
that's the reason why people dread
studying this topic the best way to
understand this topic would be by
understanding the unit circle video the
unit circle video will give you a very
good understanding about these three
functions and the remaining three
functions are just reciprocals of each
of these functions respectively so
remember cosec is reciprocal of sine SEC
is reciprocal of course and cut is
reciprocal of tan cotangent reciprocal
of tangent is easy to remember as we
have the word tangent in both the
functions
remembering that cossack is the
reciprocal of sine and SEC is the
reciprocal of cos might be a bit
difficult it would have probably been
easier if s went with s and c went with
fee anyway just make sure you note that
C goes with s and s goes with C now
let's assume that we are given the value
of sine theta with just this data will
you be able to tell me the values of the
other five functions the answer is yes
but the question is how to know how
please watch the next video
you